so Peter we recently got to take a look
at a game that's very much in the
minecraft style sort of game with a
little bit of building a little bit of
shooting a little bit of teamwork and
it's called block and load yeah jagex is
blocking load is a sort of unapologetic
game is inspired by minecraft and you
know yes it's a competitive shooter it's
team-based and the way it divides the
gameplay up is before any match starts
you literally take five minutes to
harvest resources and build things on
your team's base because so there's a
generator that you're trying to throw
behind enemy lines so it's your job to
protect yours and sort of build
fortification around it you know perhaps
so the enemy has to dig through that to
get to your generator yeah so it's
interesting that they have the the setup
period before the actual shooting begins
because it you know in traditional
minecraft style it front loads each
match with sort of a building period
where you can just sort of get creative
and you know dig a hole dig a bunker
someone on our team during the demo
built a pill box with a bunch of turrets
in there so you can get really creative
on how you want to defend your generator
before you even have to worry about
finding the other teams right and so
after the building phase the match
starts and you know teams are comprised
of different classes of characters and
as some of these characters include a
rainbow look like a sort of a tank like
giant robot and he's even a quick little
ninja type character and yeah i mean
everyone kind of runs for the generator
but ultimately you die pretty quickly in
this game if your enemies set up turrets
or if they're good at attacking you but
there's a way to sort of alleviate that
you know that punishment for going back
yeah so it's possible to build sort of
similar to the tf2 engineers teleporters
you can build spawn points throughout
the map so it's interesting because you
can dig down like minecraft you can sort
of dig into the hills or you know go
straight down and just build these
teleporters wherever and try to hide
them as best you can and its really
interesting tactic to sort of flank
around the enemy build a spawn point
behind them and hide it really well and
then you can basically just spawn in
right on their base yeah it's pretty
hard for them to find it at least it was
in my experience but of course there was
one time where I built a sky bridge out
of bricks out to a little floating
island and hit it there and I think once
someone sees that sky bridge they think
what what is going on here mr. they
figured it out pretty easily yeah and
it's interesting jagex the guys from
jagex for telling us actually that
they've sort of taken a radical
dedication approach to
just freedom and building and that they
almost didn't allow sky bridging but
they figured that it it'd be more
interesting to just let people have
creative freedom build sky bridges build
platforms that go out forever build as
far out as you can on the map and then
build a straight lain down to the
enemy's base so they're there really is
a radical amount of creative freedom in
this game which is interesting yeah and
you know I'm not necessarily a big fan
of Minecraft but pairing it with a sort
of team-based competitive shooter game I
think that it it helps you know sort of
give it more more legs in a sense the
building and harvesting yeah I am NOT a
Minecraft fan either but it was
interesting for me to have sort of the
the Lego creative approach to a game
like this but with the motivation of
another team competing against you
shooting each other and sort of a MOBA
style base capture mode yeah so if you
are a fan of team fortress 2 and
certainly minecraft keep an eye on block
and load it's going to be coming out
this April in 2015 from jagex on PC
you